[Music]
a new report is detailing what it says
are the biggest risks facing the globe
in 2022 and the findings may surprise
you it's a report that comes from the
eurasia group that's a political risk
and research consulting firm closely
watched report it ranks the top global
risks every single year and the
president and founder of eurasia group
ian bremmer joins us now to detail this
report we're going in reverse order on
the top three in number three midterm
elections here in the u.s a top risk for
2022 how come
well maybe the the least of the
surprises this is the most important
midterm election in american history
we have january 6 coming up in just a
day
and as you know since the profoundly
challenged uh and elections of 2020
no lessons have been learned at all in
the united states the country is much
more divided and a large number of
americans some 64 percent uh in an npr
poll yesterday said they thought the
united states democracy was in crisis
unlike countries like japan and germany
and uh and canada in the last few months
have had very successful elections the
united states has an election process
that is increasingly broken uh
increasingly delegitimized and the
midterm elections especially uh if you
have a significant
win uh for a trump-led republican party
means that 2024 is going to be seen as
illegitimate and potentially a
constitutional crisis in the world's
most powerful country it's hard not to
rank that high on your list it's deeply
worrying number two on the list is what
you call a techno polar world you point
out that tech firms are not going to
reign in information disinformation on
their own and as a result we have this
deeply destabilizing force out there in
the world why number two on the list
well because these tech companies are
increasingly they're sovereign in
virtual space
they're not effectively regulated they
create the world they create the
algorithms and digital space is becoming
more important in the way the economy
runs and the way national security and
personal security occurs and also in the
way we receive information everybody
increasingly is angry about different
things involving these tech companies
but if you look over the course of 2022
their power is growing faster than the
willingness and the ability of different
governments to effectively regulate them
that's even true in a country like china
and so as a consequence what we call a
techno-polar world where technology
companies act as geo-political actors in
ways that matter to international
relations and power is increasingly
becoming a disruptive force
and you mentioned china and at number
three you mentioned uh china's zero
covet policy why is that oh no wait we
got the drum roll that is number one i
mean number one i'm sorry you're going
to reverse order reverse order mention
that at the beginning yeah at number one
no
it is number one and you know the
interesting thing the the pandemic has
changed all of our lives so dramatically
in the last two years and in the west
we've responded differently as the
pandemic has changed as you know we have
you know a lot more people vaccinated a
lot more people boosted we have
increasingly therapeutics that actually
work and this disease is now much more
transmissible but it's less lethal and
that means that we're opening up and
within weeks it's going to feel endemic
in the west but in china their policies
towards the pandemic haven't changed one
iota and the most effective of the major
economies in responding to the pandemic
in 2020 was china they could track they
could trace they could quarantine they
could lack that lock down but that's
still what they're doing with omicron
that's a very serious problem for a
country where the people don't have a
lot of antibodies because almost no
one's got covet where their own vaccines
don't work effectively against omicron
and where they refuse to license mrna
vaccines from the west like pfizer and
moderna so they're going to be
increasingly locked down and they're
going to have a really hard time
responding to an extraordinarily
transmissible omicron variant this is
the second largest economy in the world
it's a big driver of global growth and
if you've got those lockdowns persisting
this year you're still going to see the
supply chain challenges you're still
going to see the inflation as a
consequence china's covet policy is
actually our top risk for 2022.
all right ian bremer bringing in the top
three things we should be concerned
about for global instability ian thank
you very much we'll keep an eye on them